anyway I like to finish  but it's not fair I can't let you get  away with that don't say I only know one  doctor that's not accurate Zach there's  more than one doctor on planet Earth who  thinks that injecting estrogen into a  man or abnormal levels of testosterone  into a woman could be bad the only point  I'm making here is that doesn't mean  that this sector of the medical industry  or America or the world means they're  bigoted or ignorant you're drawing a  conclusion I'm not I'm saying is it  within the bounds of reason that a  doctor may not want to treat that  because the science isn't in and it  doesn't necessarily make them a  transphobic bigot it's a simple question  it doesn't matter to me if there's a  couple doctors who disagree  um  and there is not unanimous agreement  that's just not accurate Zach